I'm I'm curious like how many years were
you with him before you left was it did
you say seven started from the age of 18
to
28. oh wow wow yeah so just
because I'm always just curious like
when did you realize he was abusive
so it was gradual so after probably
about the first eight months seven
months eight months
um
but it was little things can't go out
didn't want me to go to work but made it
made me feel like it was I was doing
something wrong all the time having male
friends why have you got so many male
friends
that doesn't look nice on you you don't
need to wear heels today why have you
got makeup on you guys just little
things